do germans they put up christmas trees
right the same way we do
well it is a okay so number one a
question you guys are raising your tree
and
it's there like in thanksgiving people
are building a tree
people people put up their trees kind of
early here like the minute it's december
they put
a lot of people put up their trees we
are making it 24 december there is the
tree
23 december where is the tree nautia
what i do not understand
if you have a pizza party and you invite
some people do they show up
28 days early for support
no no you think we're putting up our
trees way too early it's not cool don't
show up early to the party like what
kind of tree does that
yeah a maple perhaps perhaps a sequoia
you know yeah
it's fired this is ridiculous okay
so you you put your trees up uh just the
night before yes but the night before
yes
and uh and then what other traditions
are there are there
fun games or oh yeah your favorite
christmas gift what's a good gift to get
oh yes uh well for the tree that every
tree has a pickle
uh one pickle what do you mean like a
pickle like a pickle yeah yeah you hide
a pickle on the tree
and then if you are finding the pickle
you receive a fun treat from mama or
papa
yeah and what
what if you don't find the pickle you
don't receive the gift
wow you guys have a great you have a
great christmas
isn't that fun yeah yeah i don't like
the idea of someone hiding a pickle in
me it doesn't sound like a lot of fun
oh it is not an actual pickle it is it's
made of ceramic or porcelain so don't
drop it otherwise you will receive
stitches
yeah you know snitches receive pickles
stitches and snitch
snit don't drop the pickle yeah yep
you